der senator fragt wie stellst du deine
zukunft form sex kids und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen blog seitdem
die letzte woche ausgegangen
ich hab ich mir gedacht immer wieder in
die lok klingt logisch neuwagen bestellt
auf twitter und ich ein paar dinge zu
erzählen und deswegen treffen wir uns
heute hier so wieder
ich würde eine brauche erst nochmal
cooleren ort oder hier sind der wohnung
ist bisschen langweilig wie machen wir
das dann müssten
ich habe eine idee seid ihr bereit wir
müssen uns jetzt konzentrieren ok 123 so
und da sind wir leute jetzt guckt euch
mal hier um dabei mir den kleinen
videoclip drehen sieht ganz nett aus
würde ich mal sagen heute im hinterkopf
bisschen das plätschern auf dem boden
hier habe ich die fragen und wir legen
direkt mal loswerden das versuchen so
sowohl technisch wie möglich zu machen
italy fragt heftig es ist zeit
verschenkt du schoko weihnachtsmänner zu
ostern nicht gefällt klein paulo
coesfeld wann kommen ungefähr deine
charts das ist die frage das hängt ganz
davon ab wie man designer der christ den
kennt ihr vielleicht auch schon
deutschen sachen für max gemacht so fit
und aktiv ist sowie schneller fertig
wird er ist schon dran der hat schon ein
design glaube ich fertig das zweite muss
auch noch machen und da muss man auch
klären wie man die dinger irgendwie
verkauft und passt aber irgendwie sind
privaten laden geht die man selbst
aufzieht oder weiß netzwerk das auch
nicht alles klar
ich würde sagen so drei wochen und
monaten noch ungefähr war anstatt den
höchsten wert seit anstatt dass ihr
einen sagt okay jetzt hat er gesagt
eineinhalb wochen und dann kommt sie
nach einfacher das wollen wir auch nicht
okay nächste frage
nächste frage du luu du
hashtag erstes zeit neuer bayern nico
fragt was hast du zuletzt gegessen und
hat es dir gemundet ich habe gerade
bevor ich mich hierher begeben habe habe
ich noch ein bisschen gebuddelt und zwar
falle also dieses schmetterlings nudeln
mit pesto rosso und dazu thunfisch aber
nicht roh aber thunfisch aus der dose
was man nicht alles macht so als student
der sich irgendwie eiweißreich eine
anwältin hat astra die leute es ist
crazy aber das hat gut geschmeckt
eigentlich und ansonsten eher sie in den
letzten tagen so krass wie müsli dieses
knusprig die von rewe danke für 80
übrigens ist einfach and geil ich bin
richtig süchtig nach ich erste glauben
am tag so 300 400 gramm von das ist viel
zu viel
solltest überlassen egal mache ich
trotzdem chemie unterstrich sein fragt
was hältst du von zuschauer treffen
er stellt es ist zeit ja zuschauer
treffen finde ich ein an sich eigentlich
ganz geil ich glaube dass gerade bei mir
hier in der ecke beraten was das ist ich
noch mal drüber gucke ich das mal an das
ist einfach geil perfekte ort für den
wii fit und wii jog dass sie bei mir
eine ecke einfach nicht so viele
zuschauer sind dass das problem das
nicht herrlich köln sondern es ist nicht
berlin ich hamburger keine metropole und
es sind ich habe das gefühl weil ich
weiß von zuschauer ahnt dass die hier
wohnen aber die wissen nicht dass ich
hier wurde das ist richtig witzig dass
eine coole sache aber zuschauer treffen
finde ich im prinzip einig mega cool
gerne können gerne machen vor allem wenn
ich in köln wenn nächste mal wenn ich in
köln gescheitert wäre auf twitter ist es
gut schreibt man die kommentare ob ihr
dabei sein wollt
beim nächsten mal alle kölner kölner
zuschauer wie inside fragt wirst du zu
dem video days nach köln kommen ja das
ist geplant dafür extra aus dem urlaub
zurück sind ja wieder im nordsee urlaub
und nicht noch extra eine pause
bericht und ein video days freuen kann
das bisschen umgekehrt den
steinzeitkommunisten feuer da eine
feuerstelle hoffen ich jetzt keinen
keine aschen dreck um den rosenstein
es ist zeit wann spielst du wieder wenn
ich zeit habe ich bin gerade auf dem weg
zur uni trier hat dieses video auf dem
weg zur uni muss eigentlich ja was für
die uni machen
das problem war ich hoffe ich habe jetzt
keinen keine störgeräusche vom handy im
video falls doch tut mir leid ich habe
jetzt mal auf den flugmodus gemacht es
könnte gut sein dass wir gerne am mikro
egal passiert nix krimis an fragt auch
noch gibt es eine möglichkeit dich mal
in stuttgart zu treffen
stuttgart will ich nicht so oft ehrlich
gesagt kvasiny früher mal durchgefahren
mit dem zug
mein mitbewohner kommt aus stuttgart
will ich die man besucher vielleicht
dann müsste man aber auch ein fantreffen
mache ich hab voll bock mehr treffen das
kann man schon sagen ja so etwas fragt
weißt du schon ob du zum videodreh in
berlin kommen kannst ja weiß ich nicht
nein weiß ich noch nicht bock hätte ich
natürlich gab es anfang meine erste
zweiter mai wenn ich da keine klausuren
habe ich das irgendwie bewerkstelligt
können dass ich der günstig aufkomme
warum nicht können hätte ich bock drauf
ja ich bin halt so mehr der typ youtuber
der sowas eigentlich gerne macht sofern
treffen video dessen zweiter finde ich
cool deswegen auch klar bock darauf
jeden fall ralf finger lp grüß dich
fragt was ist hashtag es ist zeit für
ein hashtag wie soll man die frage
beantworten schreibt immer in die
kommentare was das für hersteller jetzt
etwas verbindet ihr damit ich weiß ich
kann jetzt gar nicht richtig drauf
antworten irgendein hersteller von einem
sehr kreativen dann nochmal könntest du
hallo luisa sagen sie verhüllt ich mir
hallo lisa was geht
ok zack zack zack zack zack jetzt hab
ich die fragen fast schon durch to play
charity place fragt hashtag es ist zeit
ein lieblingslied von sal
vielleicht finde ich mir ganz stark
deshalb bin ich halt persönlichen einer
indienreise das wissen ja nicht viele
von euch aber für alle die bis jetzt
dran geblieben sind ich war ja mein
indien für einen monat und denen die in
der stadt in indien bangalore heißt die
da war auch soll und hat ihnen diese
also solace und rapper den max und nicht
hören und er hat in dieser stadt der
sünde weltreise gemacht in dieser stadt
genau diesen song geschrieben und das
ist zufällig genau die stadt in indien
wo ich auch war und so die erfahrung die
er beschreibt die habe ich auch mehr
oder weniger schon so gemacht und ja
deswegen viel ich das am 6 punkt punkt
ich kann die fallen nicht ganz lesen er
senator fragt wie stellst du dir deine
zukunft vor
eine gute frage zum abschluss ja ich
hier meine zukunft vor
also ich hoffe ich habe mir ein paar
ziele gesetzt bezüglich youtube und
tritt so die ich gerne folgen möchte ich
möchte da halt dass youtube immer weiter
spaß macht weiter wächst und so dass ich
euch weiter unterhalten kann das ist ein
ziel
dann ist es irgendwann auch mein ziel in
köln zu holen ich versuche jetzt für
diesen sommer ein praktikum zu bekommen
können müsse man schauen ob das klappt
aber früher oder später köln auf jeden
fall dich lieb die stadt einfach dass da
was so auch wenn es schön ist aber köln
ist einfach
kein vergleich und ansonsten der wg mit
max wäre ich auch ganz gern dass auch so
ein bisschen in planung
da hab ich bin die ganze zeit viel zu
hoch oder nero geht schon geht schon für
zb die filmerei eine wg mit max in köln
und dann nötig von youtube so
übergangsmäßig so bisschen leben dass er
einfach mega geil das wäre ein richtiger
traum von youtube und twitter bisschen
leben zu können
einfach schön ich mag man brauche nicht
viel geld eigentlich wenn man sich ein
bisschen selbst bescheidet man als
schlimm kann man das auch irgendwann da
muss man ein bisschen lernen kohle zu
sparen und ich weiß jetzt ich will ich
brauche moment ist es nicht vielen das
kann man schon mit youtube verdienen
damit which zusammen erst recht das war
einfach geil oder in köln weiter
studieren das finde ich auch geil
ja leute das war's vom heutigen wie lok
ich habe bis jetzt mal so
zusammengefasst und abgeschlossen acht
minuten zum abschluss noch eine info für
euch und zwar der community ts kommt
bald ich war handel gerade noch mit
tomic darüber welche ip der bekommen
wird weil es kein punkt de und punkt tk
und was weiß ich alles ist schon weg
eventuell escape punkt ev ich mache das
aber noch ein separates video wie gesagt
ich habe euch ein paar fragen gestellt
wenn ihr bock hat beantwortete in den
kommentaren lassen daumen nach oben und
video wie da